does gun control actually stop gun
violence so first let's point out a
quick statistic violence statistics not
just on violence statistics violence
statistics matter it is true that if you
have an armed population in many cases
you have a more polite population
according to PolitiFact which is a far
left source for England and Wales the
rate of violent crimes is 775 per
100,000 people for the United States
that rate is 383 violent crimes per
100,000 people the UK has double the
violent crime rate of the united states
according to PolitiFact and they have
virtually no guns in their society how
about gun control in other nations what
you would expect is again this
one-to-one correlation because people
keep suggesting over and over and over
more guns means more crime okay let's
look at the European countries and take
the United States completely out of it
okay the gun homicide rate in the United
States first of all has declined faster
than Australia's did after its gun
buyback and ban program and it's hard to
measure the impact on mass shootings of
Australia's gun buyback program because
there are so few guns that there are so
few mass shootings before them but if
you look at gun control in other nations
right the small arms survey of 2007
estimates civilian ownership of firearms
by nation the United States ranks by far
at the top we have a hundred and one
guns per 100 residents number eight is
Norway number in Norway has 31 guns per
100 residents France is ninth the UK
ranks 82nd so the UK doesn't have
virtually any guns Norway has a lot more
guns okay yet Norway is near the bottom
of the list in terms of homicide rate
just 0.5 six murders per 100,000
inhabitants and Frank's France rather
ranks somewhere near the middle of the
pack they've tripled the homicide rate
of Norway but they have way fewer guns
which suggests that maybe this has very
little to do with guns and it has a lot
more to do with the population that is
in your country and you see this in the
United States too right there are states
there's no correlation whatsoever
between a state having a high firearm
ownership rate and a high crime rate so
the 10 lowest homicide jurisdictions for
in in the United States are New
Hampshire Vermont Iowa Massachusetts
Utah Minnesota Maine Hawaii Idaho and
Wyoming six of those 10 states or an ad
or an F from the Brady Campaign on gun
control
being if you go to Vermont or New
Hampshire everybody has a gun and
there's no gun violence and the reason
for that is because the people in
Vermont in New Hampshire are not
shooting each other this is really not
all that difficult and when you look at
the other end of the spectrum when you
look at the states that do have high
rates of gun violence there are a bunch
of states actually they have a lot of
gun control and of course everybody in
the Second Amendment community is
familiar with localities like Washington
DC and Chicago